und ich sage ihnen genau so soll es
wieder in new york aussehen und das
trotz corona und trotz seiner
intelligenz von
3.600 ich zitiere wir können es uns
nicht leisten dass die stadt weiter in
die wirtschaftliche hoffnungslosigkeit
rutscht das ist die begründung des
gerade frisch gewählten bürgermeisters
eric adams ja dass zum einen und zum
anderen behaupten organisationen wie die
whu europa unter berufung auf eine
hochrechnung ein weiteres argument warum
es vielleicht gar nicht so abwegig ist
von strengen maßnahmen wie unseren
aktuellen abzusehen wenn wir corona also
eh bekommen warum versuchen wir dann
nicht auch eine lockerung wie in new
york city hier sehen wir noch mal das
zitat von hans kluge wir rechnen damit
dass ich in den nächsten sechs bis acht
wochen mehr als 50 prozent der
europäischen bevölkerung mit omikron
infizieren wird ja deshalb die frage
warum also dann überhaupt noch die
maßnahmen unser reporter herbert
bauernebel ist für uns in new york und
berichtet über die lage vor ort
new york die stadt die niemals schläft
new york die stadt die niemals schließt
die amerikanische metropole eröffnet
trotz dreitausender incidents alle türen
keine zweig regel oder sonstige
einschränkungen
zum vergleich berlin hat eine 800er
inzidenz und in restaurants kommt man
trotz impfung nur noch mit testreihen in
new york ist jeder vierte aktuell krank
die die können müssen arbeiten so
bürgermeister adams zurück zur
normalität koste es was es wolle doch
nicht alle finden das richtig dr paul
hayes gefäßchirurg spricht über die lage
in den krankenhäusern der turbo s ist
keine schlimme krankheit aber es
verbreitet sich sehr sehr schnell
zwischen menschen es ist jetzt nicht so
dass wir viele menschen haben die
beatmet werden müssen oder auf der
intensivstation liegen aber die zahl der
menschen die sich infizieren kann unser
system überlassen und auch die
krankenhausmitarbeiter überlasten
touristen hingegen freuen sich über den
offenen umgang mit omikron sehr ganz
entspannt am flughafen war es entspannt
und auch hier die leute sind alle nett
da wir sind froh dass es das überhaupt
touristen da sind man kann alles machen
wir können alles sehen sind keine große
reisegruppe und ich denke
wird es uns auch nicht wirklich etwas
passieren eingekauft wird hier also ganz
normal am big apple geimpft oder
genesenen regel gibt es hier nicht die
gute nachricht hier in new york ist der
zenit scheint überschritten man hat nur
das masken mandat verschärft und
natürlich weiterhin die bevölkerung
aufgerufen sich impfen zu lassen so
gesehen ist der big apple hier relativ
normal durchgekommen durch diese welle
es gab hier keinen lockdown wie einst
zum horror ausbruch im frühjahr 2020 es
gab
moderate maßnahmen eigentlich kaum
veränderungen zur zeit vor micro new
york geht also einen anderen weg
hauptsache 1 nicht schließen
ja aber und sieht es anders aus harte
maßnahmen im sinne von 2g plus und vor
allem auch hatte quarantäne regeln das
sorgt vor allem in der wirtschaft und in
den sogenannten systemrelevanten berufen
für stress zum beispiel bei der
feuerwehr in bremen die musste nun sogar
einen krisenstab einrichten unser
reporter gerd schröder ist nun vor ort
geld du wirst in begleitung wen hast du
genau wir sind jetzt hier genau bei der
feuerwache in bremen hinter uns wird
also in ungefähr 15 minuten der
krisenstab der feuerwehr tagen um im
grunde auch zu beraten wie geht es
weiter denn die inzidenz hier in bremen
liegt bei fast 1500 das heißt warnstufe
vier ausgerufen und bremen der
eigentliche impfen meister von
deutschland ist plötzlich ein
spitzenreiter als bundesland mit der
inzidenz und neben mir steht jetzt
michael richert der leiter der
rettungsleitstelle und
feuerwehrleitstelle hier in bremen und
auch pressesprecher erich hat wie geht
weiter an bremen bietet bei der
feuerwehr aus mit denen corinna fehlen
ja wir machen uns sorgen das kann man
nicht anders sagen wir haben ein wenig
sorge auch dass die hohen instanzen auch
in die kritische infrastruktur
überschwappen wir sind darauf
vorbereitet wir leben jetzt zwei jahre
in dieser pandemie wir haben uns schon
am anfang der pandemie genau für diese
fälle pläne zurecht gelegt und wir leben
in sehr strengen regeln gerade um genau
zu verhindern dass wir irgendwie in
gefahr raten nicht mehr in den einsatz
gehen zu können also wir leben ganz
streng in kurorten die wachabteilung an
sich bilden eigene kurden eigentlich
rücken unsere löschfahrzeuge besetzt mit
sechs personen aus das haben jetzt
aufgeteilt auf zwei fahrzeuge einfach um
die gruppen kleiner zu machen ganz
streng ist tragen von ffp zwei masken
wir haben bei den freiwilligen
feuerwehren den allgemeinen dienst
untersagt die rücken jetzt tatsächlich
zur zeit nur noch aus einfach um kontakt
zu vermeiden dass versuchen auf allen
ebenen auch im tagesdienst home office
ist ein großes thema bei uns also
kontakte vermeiden personengruppen
verkleinern einschränken das ganze hat
wirkung gezeigt das heißt die erkrankung
innerhalb der feuerwehr sind
überschaubar aber man spürt sie oder ja
also wir spüren sie also wir sind bei
der berufsfeuerwehr rund 700
beschäftigte und da haben wir derzeit
akut 13 fälle 313 infizierte bei elf
personen wissen wir noch nicht was bei
rauskommt also wir reden jetzt von so
einer zahl von 25 bei der freiwilligen
feuerwehr haben wir aktuell sechs
infizierte also einig sieht es ganz gut
aus und ich hoffe dass wir diesen stand
auch so halten können wie geht es dann
weiter wenn jetzt diese infektionswelle
auch die feuerwehr größe erfasst wie
kann sich die feuerwehr darauf
vorbereiten auch im ernstfall
rettungsdienst und feuerwehr einsätze
abzuarbeiten genau das haben wir vor
geplant also wir würden diese kohorten
die wir jetzt schon haben nochmal enger
fassen also jetzt arbeiten wir zum
beispiel im einsatzdienst im lösch und
hilfeleistungs dienst im 24 stunden
dienst in drei fachabteilungen
möglicherweise würde man diese
wachabteilung reduzieren auf 2 wir
arbeiten in der leitstelle derzeit in
zwölf stunden schichten da könnte man
überlegen auf 24 stunden schichten zu
gehen einfach also die dienst intervalle
würden größer werden die arbeitszeiten
natürlich verlängert werden also würden
versuchen einfach diese scorten prinzip
noch zu intensivieren und die impfquote
innerhalb der feuerwehr scheint ja auch
hoch zu sein sagt und gerade sie liegen
deutlich über 90 prozent sogar bei der
feuerwehr oder ja genau ich glaube das
ist auch das was uns jetzt gerade so ein
bisschen an der oberfläche hält die gute
impfquote willigen sogar bei 94 prozent
deswegen
sich dass es so bleibt vielen dank
michael richert für diese auskünfte
direkt vor der sitzung des krisenstabes
hier in bremen und die impfquote in
bremen ist ja ohnehin hoch wir liegen in
bremen bei einer impfquote von 88
prozent und die booster rom sind auch
schon zu 50 prozent durchgeführt und
trotzdem ist bremen eben ganz jetzt
spitzenreiter geworden in sachen der
incidents vielen dank für die einblicke
in bremen garrett schritt
ja wir sehen die wege mit omikron
umzugehen die sind verschieden die usa
machen auf trotzdem dreitausender
inzidenz schweden war einst ja erstmal
sehr locker im umgang entschied sich
aber nun dazu die maßnahmen wieder zu
verschärfen in spanien wiederum denkt
man darüber nach corona nicht nur wie
eine grippe einzustufen ja und auch wir
dagegen sind nach wie vor auf einem
strengen kurs zweige plus und das obwohl
unsere zahlen von der new yorker
inzidenz noch weit weg sind schauen wir
uns die aktuellen zahlen an der thomas
du hast das kronach bruder für uns
[Musik]
ganz genau auf weit weg von new york
aber auch hier hoch das robert koch
institut meldet heute morgen einen neuen
rekord die zahl der neuinfektionen bin
der letzten 24 stunden ist auf 81
1417 gestiegen noch mal mehr als gestern
als zum ersten mal die schwelle von
80.000 überschritten wurde zum vergleich
vor einer woche lagen wir bei ungefähr
65.000 dieser rasante anstieg noch mal
hat auch mit den nachmeldungen zu tun
die jetzt nach den feiertagen erst
eingetrudelt sind die sieben tage
instituts 400 27,7 auch noch mal hoch
gegangen von
407 gestern und todesfälle bin 24
stunden 360 in 316 in deutschland im
vergleich zu 443 vor einer woche das ist
also zurückgegangen ganz interessant
noch in diesem zusammenhang die aussage
von gesundheitsminister karl lauterbach
der gesagt hat dass das ziel einer 80
prozent quote bei den impfungen bei den
erst impfungen bis ende januar offenbar
nicht zu erreichen sein wird er sagte es
wird sehr schwer das ist klar bislang
sind in deutschland
74,8 prozent oder 62 millionen menschen
zumindest einmal geimpft schauen wir auf
die hospitalisierung inzidenz die ja
maßgeblich ist für die beschränkungen
alles was über drei ist dort muss eine
zweig regel gelten und dort wo es über 6
ist ein zweig plus regel da sehen wir
das hat sich eigentlich verbessert wenn
wir gerade hier im süden sehen sind wir
deutlich unter 3 in vielen grünen
flächen hier dort einziger ausreißer
bremen wir haben es vorhin gesagt
garrett hat es gesagt trotz der hohen
impfquote von 88% die hospitalisierung
incidents dort in bremen sehr hoch das
bildet sich natürlich auch in den hot
spots ab das sehen wir hier das ist
bremen ansonsten land durchschnittlicher
wir haben es gesagt 400 ist die in sie
denn da sehen wir dass sich das eben
auch auf der landkarte so abbildet alles
in rot